[Music]
welcome back did you clean up your room
today or do you need some inspo let's
check in with rocky she's live at
inspired closets with spring cleaning
tips on this national clean up your room
day
hey rocky
hey jc and the answer is no i did not
clean up my room today of course and but
i am standing
in the middle of my dream closet look
how fabulous this is here at inspired
closets
a special showroom that's going to get
us ready for spring cleaning right
that's right
all right so first step when you're
spring cleaning it's about purging
correct dominic
no no we don't like to use the word okay
purge comes with like a negative vibe it
does
we want to go into this positively so we
call it editing so we're going to go
through and we're going to
edit all of the stuff out the stuff we
don't typically need
we can see this person kind of has a
color palette going on so there's some
things that just don't fit within that
color palette
i'm not gonna wear them anymore i'm
going for it okay so the best thing to
do i think
when you're editing your closet is to
first have a team right exactly so we've
got esme over here
she's gonna help us i'm gonna throw my
clothes over to you that i don't want
and we have three baskets here
right labeled what we gotta decide what
to do we can either donate
we can sell we can trash it so if it has
holes tears it's used it's worn let's
trash
it if it's good usable condition go
ahead donate it okay
there's something maybe you sell the
tags on something really valuable you
may want to sell it
look at that i love the tag on this one
okay so i'm going to sell it
exactly yeah
what else are we going to get rid of
here are you going to wear that no i'm
not going to think first of all it's
been in my closet so long it's just too
small
right so let's go donate it we'll donate
it let's donate it yeah there's someone
no it's going to fit perfect okay
now i'm this is the last thing i'm
getting rid of don't make me get over
any
anything else dominate okay don't make
me get rid of anything else we can still
make this look better
okay i'm gonna let's trash this
that just yeah i'm done it's all right
so now what do we do dominic
all right so the my favorite thing is to
sort by sleeve length and color
so right now our sleeves are pretty good
they could be better so we want to take
all of our tank tops and kind of move
them to the front
also make sure that you take out any
unused hangers so that way when you're
doing laundry you always have a spot
with your hangers for quick easy access
i like that and i just want to make a
note guys because i feel really good
about this
i do have the space-saving hangers
space-saving hangers a game changer
right
i do have those in my messy closet yeah
it's a learning curve some people have
to get used to them
once you do it it saves so much space
they look great they look so good they
come in all different colors
yeah if you have all the different
colors of the rainbow in your closet
it's always going to look chaotic
stick to one hanger exactly so we're
sleeves
um colors first
okay we'll move that one over here um
why aren't you guys getting inspired you
want to clean your room right now
exactly
with me we're going to move all these
short sleeves over here okay
now everything kind of falls at a
different sleeve length and you can see
this is going to be my more summery or
under-dressing things these are going to
be my coats towards the back
work blouse jacket i love that exactly
let's move on now because obviously
clothes
purging great next biggest problem yeah
yeah shoes are my problem so i have too
many shoes not enough space
for high heels luckily there's a really
cool way to store them that saves space
typically if you try to pay attention
take notes on this one right it looks
easy it looks really simple and it is
so if you try to fit two into a smaller
space like this it's always going to
look off
all you have to do is just turn that
heel
on one of those shoes and now you fit
two in this phase of one right
and it looks good it looks good because
sometimes the heel looks better from the
back
so you get to see the full shoe now
donna you are the expert obviously i'm
learning so much also baskets are really
important
baskets are my go-to definitely okay so
coming up in the four o'clock we're
going to talk about folding
with the experts so we'll be back later
that's awesome thank you rocky we'll
check back in with you during the 4
pm newscast